na'vi are replacing simple Yes simple
according to a report put out earlier
today by hltv na'vi are in advanced
talks to sign wonderful the promising
upand cominging Ukrainian oper who
previously played for team spirit and
most recently spreaded the report
claimed that should the deal get
finalized he would be replacing none
other than simple now on paper this
makes sense they're both opers they're
both really talented it's just
like simple now for those who aren't
familiar with who wonderful is he is an
18-year-old Ukrainian op Prodigy who
like simple plays on a really high
sensitivity is a really ballsy player he
actually has been referred to as a mini
simple in the past and these players
actually have something of a history um
obviously there's a respect between
simple and the young up incomer but this
happened a couple months ago running at
him
so yeah as to why na'vi would want to
sign wonderful it makes a [__] ton of
sense he's a really talented player he's
very very young he hasn't quite found
that roster to fit in with yet that
makes sense what didn't make sense was
why they would want to replace simple to
begin with now for those who didn't know
and I'm sure there's not many of you who
didn't know this past weekend at IM
Sydney the first big CS2 tournament
simple actually wasn't in attendance
simple hasn't been mincing his words
when it comes to to his not so great
impression of CS2 and a lot of people
were sort of swelling rumors that this
might be the reason that he was sitting
at the tournament now this wasn't the
case apparently as due to a report by
dexerto it became clear that simple just
had to sort out some paperwork issues to
do with EU residency of course people
couldn't help but sort of hound simple
on stream and wonder rightfully when
he'd be showing up to a CS2 event willj
next year to event hopefully yes now
it's not necessarily a secret that
simple isn't the biggest fan of CS2
which let's be honest the game has
issues I feel like he feels about the
game the way that most of us feel and
there was this whole story from a couple
days ago about how valve DMD him and he
left them on red and we actually made a
video about it and a lot of people had
thoughts about whether he should have
responded didn't respond which you
should check out if you haven't seen it
but I think it's fair to say that it
doesn't really make sense that simple
would be getting replaced on na'vi
because he isn't the biggest fan of CS2
the game has a ton of problems and most
of us recognize what those problems are
now there report did say that according
to one particular Source simple was
looking to take a break from competition
which I mean let's be honest makes a ton
of sense the guy's been going really
really hard for the entire duration of
his pro career like eight years at this
point he's won a major he's w a slam he
works really hard there's obviously also
a lot of political and presumably
personal stuff going on with his life
right now CS2 is sort of in shambles in
a word I get it I find it believable and
then earlier today simple released this
tweet where he basically cleared the air
and just said that he was in fact
looking to take a break he claimed it's
only half the story however and that one
of the reasons he wanted to take a break
was to basically handle some personal
stuff in his life that he didn't really
go into too deeply just claimed that he
need to fix documents and take care of
presumably his family he also explicitly
addressed the issue of switching to
another org and said he never thought
about it which I mean this clocks with
what we know about simple he's always
wanted to play for Na stayed with na'vi
through thick and thin but he did say
he'd be interested in seeing offers
however maybe as a rifler not as an oper
since right now the op is not super
impactful in the game though it remains
to be seen for how long that stays the
case anyway he basically says nothing is
decided yet and you know he still wants
us a sh for na'vi and he's still on
great terms with the org and yeah anyway
for right now that's basically it lot of
absolutely ballistic roster news over
the last couple of days and I just know
that before this video even comes out
there's going to be some other bomb that
gets dropped at us when we know more so
will you we'll keep you updated have a
good
one